[Applaudissements]
ça marche très bien
avec vous absolument je suis très
content et alors comme d'hab j'ai
parcouru toute l'actu et les interviews
politiques de la semaine pour vous faire
découvrir les meilleurs moments qui se
passent dans le gauche à droite
cette semaine s'il y avait un nom à bien
articuler c'est bien celui du député
Jérôme baloges et attention la frontière
elle est assez fine bonjour
sans transition monsieur balajou
monsieur baloche merci
le quotidien toujours sur France Info à
chaque fin d'interview les journalistes
ont tellement l'habitude que Samuel
Étienne prenne le relais
du coup ils sont complètement paumés si
jamais il est pas là merci beaucoup
Julien Audoux bonne journée à vous
et bien écoutez j'attends Samuel
[Rires]
de l'éducation nationale je m'attendais
à un meilleur niveau en maths quand même
de la part de Clément Baule le ministre
de transport
4 euros vont dans les caisses de l'État
10 %. oui
quand elle en sortait enfin elle
replongée direct c'est qui les
personnalités préférées des Français
c'est Killian Mbappé c'est Yannick Noah
[Applaudissements]
origines d'autres pays ce sont les
habitants
[Applaudissements]
ces personnes jouent au site ne sont pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah le gars il a une déduction de malade
les travailleurs sans papiers non pas de
papier
alors Maxime malheureusement l'une des
actus de la semaine c'est cet attaque au
couteau qui a eu lieu jeudi dernier à
Annecy et moi qui est un peu l'habitude
des interviews politiques maintenant je
peux vous dire que j'ai jamais vu autant
d'invité de d'extrême droite débouler
sur les plateaux télé et ils ont bien
surfer sur toute la vague ce weekend
bonjour Laurent jacobelli bonjour
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan bonjour Marine Le
Pen bonjour Eric Zemmour bonjour
madame bonjour Jean-Michel bonjour
Sébastien Chenu
un homme s'est levé Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan pour dire non à la
récupération politique et aux amalgames
surtout moi je pense qu'il est très
important qui est ce temps d'émotion
naturelle et n'attendez pas de moi des
polémiques ce matin ah ouais bon ça
c'était à 832 parce que dès 8h34 bah le
temps d'émotion était déjà fini
d'absence de maîtrise de notre
immigration nous ne maîtrisons plus rien
ça suffit ça suffit on est presque à 450
000 sans compter les clandestins c'est
ingérable le pays va exploser et je ne
souhaite pas qu'on mette de l'huile sur
le feu je suis quelqu'un de raisonnable
et puis sur Sud Radio ils savent
recevoir les politiques comme s'ils
invités le seigneur des sites la musique
est d'origine il n'y a pas de montage
[Musique]
c'est le retour de l'Empire l'Empire
bruxellois contre-attaque alors cette
fois-ci il est question de migrants
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour monsieur le
député bonjour c'est tous au feu Dark
Vador et d'ailleurs le député
bonjour bonjour
bonjour
Jean-Philippe bonjour Jean-Philippe
Tanguy bonjour Jean-Philippe Tanguy
bonjour bonjour et même si Sonia Mabrouk
a l'habitude de poser des questions par
déstabiliser ses invités à mon avis sa
question aurait vite trouvé sa réponse
sur C8 bienvenue sur Europe 1 et bonjour
Sarah bonjour elle vous dit merci
qui dit merci un grand merci
qui dit merci
[Rires]
direct ici les premiers cœurs on est
d'accord
bon après la politique à l'action finit
avec les réseaux sociaux chaque jour on
voit passer énormément de vidéos sur les
réseaux et les meilleurs sont dans ma
méthodes
allez c'est parti pour Provins ou même
ce groupe de potes s'amuse avec la
nouvelle mode du kwakoubet trop cool
quoi
[Musique]
la finale de Roland-Garros ce weekend à
Paris l'occasion pour ce mec de nous
donner quelques conseils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si les jumeaux ont souvent l'habitude
de tout faire pareil bah ce petit gars
aurait dû éviter pour le coup
un message spécial aujourd'hui pour
Maxime Guéry
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous tous merci Ludivine merci
Jean-Michel merci à vous tous